now you've worked with uh mr tucci
haven't you kate
yes hello okay
yes see gary goes gagging on his boobs i
know i know
i'm very happy to see you very very
happy to see you too so presumably
you've experienced
uh stan lee's cooking no i haven't
experienced
stanley's cooking which is a tragedy
because clearly you're a marvelous chef
but
sally do you remember how much you
complained
when we worked together he would come
into work and he would say after
breakfast half an hour late he'd say
i'm i mean i'm starving i mean there's
there's nothing to eat
i mean what do you do there's there's no
food i mean this is awful this is
this is just awful and then the next day
he came into work carrying this very
sort of neat and tidy little cooler bag
actually it's quite a large cooler bag
to be fair and it was full
of these perfectly prepared little
tupperwares
full of incredible delights and
everyone's like oh leaning in oh
stanley he's like no
[Laughter]
well yeah you know you're you you know
you have to eat
well don't you when you're working you
have to eat well
i don't
and i didn't know that but you told me
that on the set
she told me she said i i can't remember
what we were talking about but you said
i'm pregnant and and she did that scream
whisper
you know and i said oh yes i did wonder
you yes you look really fat you look
really fat your boobs are huge but
you're still not having any of my
snacks yeah even though you're eating
for two yeah you're reading for two
this tupperware is sealed